associate direct director here at Simons
and for those of you who are unfamiliar
with the Simons Institute we're the
leading international venue for
collaborative research in theoretical
computer science we bring together
researchers from all over the world um
uh in theoretical computer science and
related fields and I'd like to welcome
you today to the uh workshop on matching
markets and this Workshop um is convened
partly to Mark the publication of the
book online and matching BAS Market
design that came out of existence
because of the uh the Simons program in
2019 on the same topic um just to cover
a few logistics for today uh food is
provided before the talks and during the
breaks for lunch you're on your own but
you're in Berkeley so there are many
great eateries nearby uh we ask that you
not bring food uh into the auditorium
and there are lockers on the far side on
the first floor if you want to leave
something when you go out to lunch um
and our videographer Omid far will help
speakers get set up for their talks um
so I want to thank uh Ashley Freda and
lra who were instrumental in putting
together the logistics and
accommodations for the workshop today
and I want to thank the organizers FJ
vasani Fredrico e Ean and Nicole IM Mora
for putting together a great program and
I'm gonna hand it over to
fro thank you yeah I think um thank you
so much Sandy I think you said
everything that I was going to say so
yeah so the origin of this is the first
of all the matching program that um that
uh we had here at Simons uh right before
the pandemic and then the the book that
this uh give R to that you know forms
the core of the speakers uh for today
and um uh and also it's unfortunate that
VJ couldn't be here because he was
really the driving force force behind
all of this both the the the program
Simons um the book uh the the four
chapters that the three of us wrote you
know really VJ wrote those chapters this
is um and and you know he was his idea
his initiative uh and uh yeah so
hopefully he can be here tomorrow at Le
soon and um yeah so I propos that we do
econ style introductions for the
workshop so it be very
brief the first speaker doesn't really
need an introduction is Paul milram um
so you want to get started Paul sure
and turn it
off and he's
got for I'm very happy our first speaker
is Paul M who's going to talk about
algorithmic mechanism design
yeah well thank you thank you fed fedo
um for um nice and intruction um uh I'm
also missing VJ here VJ encouraged me to
talk about newer research I asked him
whether he wanted me to talk about what
was in the book and he said well you
know uh he always wants to encourage new
research so he said go do it and uh I
wanted to show you that an old guy can
still do research so um uh with uh some
of my former students Muhammad akbarpur
and and shangu Lee and a current student
Kevin Lee and a colleague Scott
commoner's big group of people ended up
getting involved in this um the
questions we asked we were we're
noticing that one of the great things
that's happened at the boundary of of uh
econ and CS is uh uh certain ideas now
are being imported from CS back into
econ uh but we wanted to continue this
as a two-way street uh ideas from from
econ uh into into Cs and one of the
things that we were thinking about in
terms of algorithmic mechanism design is
the way um the way algorithmic mechanism
design is done by CS researchers
typically is you know you you you find
an algorithm you talk about how it's um
uh its performance and how it's affected
by incentives and how it's implemented
but economists are also often interested
in in uh incorporating mechanisms in
larger systems so you might be
interested for example instead of taking
the resources as given if you were to
run this mechanism what investment
incentives would it create that's sort
of the simplest basic idea so we decided
to uh uh treat the question of uh
algorithmic mechanism Design Within uh
within uh with Investments and the main
question that we uh want to ask um well
the initial research question
algorithmic mechanism design identifies
algorithms that produce nearly efficient
allocations and uh and pricing that
supplements the algorithm to create a
truthful mechanism but uh do nearly
efficient truthful mechanisms
incentivize nearly uh efficient
Investments that's the uh uh question we
wanted to ask and we're going to do it
in the Cs style which is to say worst
case type of
analysis so um think for this group it
hardly needs saying I put this up here
partly because vj's up is one of the
authors of one of the books but uh
there's really a vast literature about
fast approximation algorithms for for
hard problems and the theorems emphasize
worst case guarantees for quality of the
approximation and and computation time
um we wanted to ask this different
question um uh so again for those of you
who are who are not familiar with this
which which is probably nobody in this
audience but just we'll so I'll go over
it very quickly uh algorithms take as
inputs of values and constraints and
then they select an allocation or an
outcome as a result um if the values are
private information then the
computations have to rely on reported
values and the analysis of incentives
for truthful reporting comes up so we
use reported values and we provide
incentives by offering payments that
that um uh that depend on the uh on the
reports and the uh question uh about
whether we can Implement an algorithm by
a mechanism is uh which when do there
exist payment rules that incentivize
truthful reporting um for the mechanism
and what are those rules what payment
rules do that um okay now I'm going to
specialize this talk for Simplicity to
packing problems I'll talk about the
generalization later but um uh for
example the napsack problem is a
well-known hard problem for which there
are good fast approximation algorithms
but the solving it to optimality is is
NP hard um and I'm interested in packing
problems for other reasons as well there
are other packing problems besides the
napsack problem that are of interest in
applications um the napsack problem or
packing problem simplifi the notation a
bit um I'm going to say that um uh for
player n player n has a value of being
packed in the general model uh VN is a
vector which specifies values for each
outcomes I'm just going to deal with the
special model where the value of not
being packed is zero and the value of
being packed is is VN um we have some
set of feasible packing Capital Omega we
have a function that uh of the data
given values for each of the uh items um
this is the Set uh that will be packed
and the realized welfare the objective
being maximized well the if you're using
algorithm X and you get inputs V uh then
um we sum over the all the people uh xn
is one if the if n is packed and xn is
zero if n's not packed so suming uh uh
VN dox V v.x gives you the total welfare
which is the objective of these problems
so that's what I mean by packing
problems and that's the notation I'll
use um the packing constraints whatever
they are um are summarized in in capital
Omega okay and uh have some additional
notation the um the constrained
Optimizer um is um we which we call xor
V given s is when you add some
additional constraints to the uh uh to
the problem so when we you you choose
the um the argument that maximizes
welfare uh subject to uh being not only
in Omega but also in s okay uh xar
without the the thing is the global
Optimum that's when there is no extra
constraint uh the optimal welfare uh is
what you get when you use this uh
optimizing algorithm xar and the pay any
payments that are made to individual end
is a function of the report so P subn so
ends payment depends on uh uh the report
uh uh VN that it reports as well as the
these that the other others
report okay now um here we there the
analysis is going to involve some
economic traditional economic Concepts
when a player value uh changes from VN
to VN Tilda so for example due to an
investment the externality is the wedge
between the change in 's payment and the
change in others welfare so the idea is
that when I make an investment if that
affects you either benef for example if
uh uh if it takes resources away from
you I should be paying for those
resources to ensure efficient investment
and the wedge between those is called an
externality
and the externality associated with
algorithm X and prices p is this is the
change in the payment and this is the
change in the welfare for the other
people I'm uh I'm signing the payment so
the payment is a payment to the
individual um if it's a payment from the
individual it's a negative number and
that's why the things have the signs
that they do um if the investment cost
is low enough uh player n may choose to
invest to increase its net profit by
some amount Delta then the net welfare
increases by this amount this is the
increase in the profit that the
individual uh occurs plus this
externality um that's represents the uh
increase in net welfare so if I have an
externality a positive externality in
you on plus 10 and I make a profit of
five by making the investment then the
total welfare Will Rise by
15 and um so here's a summary of the
main findings of the paper which I will
be going through um first um all
non-optimizing algorithms everything
that's not optimal uh entail non-zero
externalities uh and can therefore lead
to welfare um uh reducing Investments
that is I can either fail to make an
investment when I should or or make an
because there there's going to be a
difference between uh the welfare
evaluation of an investment and the um
and the private evaluation of the
investment
um depending they can also lead they can
always lead to welfare reducing
Investments okay uh sure but uh won't
good approximations have small
externalities you might think and that's
what makes the talk interesting is that
no um in fact uh we can have a fully
polinomial time approximation system
that consists entirely of algorithms
that guarantee only a zero fraction of
possible net welfare when a single agent
can invest no matter how good these
algorithms are as an approxim and
approximating uh efficiency in the
allocation problem they can provide
terrible um incentives for investment
I'll show that by
example okay ouch okay that's bad
uh do all approximation based algorithms
have bad investment
guarantees no um an algorithm that
excludes confirming negative
externalities which we'll call XOne
algorithms and that's XOne is a New
Concept that's introduced in this paper
um confirming negative externalities is
another New Concept I'll show you
exactly what those mean um they have the
same investment guarantees as their
allocative guarantees so if you have an
algorithm that satisfies this I
condition and it guarantees you
95% um in worst case in the allocation
problem then it also guarantees you 95%
in any investment problem uh that you
might make associated with it so this is
an additional new condition that you
would want to add to um whatever else
you are using to evaluate your algorithm
to ensure that you didn't get any
degradation in the
performance uh okay but are are there
any useful XC cone algorithms can can we
find anything like that yes uh we
introduce a new X cone fbas for the
napsack problem that is we take uh we
find a another fully polinomial time
approximation system um for the napsack
problem in which each one of the
algorithms is X cone and therefore it's
also if if it guarantees 95% for the uh
uh for the allocation the knapsack
problem it still guarantees 95% when you
add an
invesment okay uh does the guarantee
change if the investor investor must
decide subject to uncertainty so when we
wrote the first version of this paper it
was all deterministic and what the
referees objected to it says nobody
makes Investments under certainty what
if there's uncertainty what if the uh
investor doesn't know other people's
values or how big the napsack is or what
the outcome of his investment will be
and uh uh but uh uncertainty doesn't
affect the guarantee we show that the
worst case problem is always
deterministic so you can put in
uncertainty about all that stuff and the
conclusion uh remains
unchanged and then uh okay but surely
there's some drawback to all of this
and yes uh uh the the theorem that I
I'll show you this it's it's true in the
generality that I've shown you for the
for packing problems packing problems
have um something special that there's a
threshold uh value such that if you're
above the threshold you know you get
packed if you're below the threshold you
don't get packed um the there there's a
threshold between any two outcomes there
only are two outcomes for an individual
you're either packed or unpacked if you
try try to generalize this to the case
where there's n possible outcomes or or
more than two possible outcomes the uh
the theorem is still true if there's a
threshold Vector that makes you just
indifferent among um all the outcomes
but if there's not then the theorem
changes so so we don't have this
completely nailed for um uh for General
problems unless we add the condition
that the possible value vectors are is a
product of intervals basically that you
can s get
speci okay so those are the main
findings and I'll get through as much of
them as I can in my remaining what 30
minutes is that what I've got
yes okay so
um I I imagine that a lot of this is
known to a lot of you but I'll go over
some of it because probably some of you
don't have it we're GNA say that a
packing algorithm is monotone if for
each item n there's a threshold um such
that item n is packed if its uh value
exceeds the threshold and it's not
packed if its value is less than the
threshold okay so for example greedy
algorithms and optimization algorithms
lots of algorithms um have
monotonicity a direct
mechanism uh I think everybody knows
what a direct mechanism is is is
truthful if for all uh value vectors the
truthful reporting is a Nash equilibrium
of the mechanism so if everybody else is
reporting truthfully uh you can't do
better than report truthfully no matter
what the value factor is um and the
threshold payment rule which is the last
definition is the payment rule that says
that when you win uh the amount you pay
is your threshold value so if if if for
me to be packed under this current
circumstance I have to report a value
higher than six um and uh if I report
less than six I'm unpacked then
threshold pricing means that if I'm
packed I'm charged a price of six if I'm
not packed I I pay
zero okay and the theorem is that a
direct mechanism is truthful if and only
if the uh underlying algorithm is
monotone in the sense that's defined
above and that there are some functions
uh F such that the amount that the
basically it say basically it tells you
that the threshold payment rule is
unique you can take the threshold
payment Rule and you can add a function
of whatever everybody else says so my
threshold is six uh if I get packed I
pay six and in addition um I pay some
function of what everybody else uh has
paid but I pay that anyway I pay that
whether I'm packed or not so there's
some as a function of what everybody
else says I pay three and if I'm packed
I pay an additional six the additional
amount is always has to be the threshold
uh uh and that's this is all all of the
the truthful algorithms all of the
truthful mechanisms for these
problems um and I'm going to skip over
the proof there isn't a bunch of time
for that the the key is to stick in the
envelope theorem at some point and get a
representation of the of the guy's
utility that doesn't have the payment
rule in it and compare it to a
representation that does and that proves
that the whole thing is unique but we'll
skip over all that
okay um a famous example uh that uses
optimization is the vicory Clark Grove
pivot mechanism um so here's an example
application uh suppose that we have an
airline flight and there are more seats
booked than there are seats on the plane
passengers P exceed the number of seats
s um and so we do is we ask each each
passenger how valuable is it to you to
fly we want to buy buy away some of your
rights and give you cash instead maybe
then you take a later flight or
something oops it's this what's a
certificate that
is just
canel um the S passengers with the
highest values are seated and they're
charged a price equal to the S Plus
first highest value uh others are not
seated in Pay zero that's called a
uniform uh price auction and that's a an
example of vicory Clark Grove pivot
mechanism you know what I can do I think
I could just turn off the this right
turn the Wi-Fi off and disappear
yes all right
um You have to click on the slide I have
to click on the slide
now what's going on
so um the pivot the general case of the
pivot
mechanism well
okay there's a general case of the pivot
mechanism is uh shown here too um it's
in for a packing problem uh the the you
might charge different so an a this is a
packing problem at the top too we have
seats and the we have a limit that we've
got 40 seats on the plane we can have 40
people um who are who are packed that is
Seated on the plane more General packing
problems are U uh are shown down here
and
umro me optimizes and charges the price
uh equal to the threshold price to
incentivize each person to report
TR okay so there are three more things
that I will try to get through at least
in part during my remaining minutes
minutes the first are um how algorithms
determine investment incentives uh now
notice it says algorithms determine
investment incentives the key thing here
is that normally we think of payment
rules as determining investment
incentives but the uhu uh the uniqueness
result that I showed you says basically
uh any algorithm has a payment rule
That's Unique up to this constant that's
added that doesn't depend on what you
report uh it doesn't depend your value
and consequently it doesn't affect your
investment incentives so it's going to
turn out that um the main point at the
top is that only uh only from the
algorithm alone without asking about the
payment rule we can figure out which
your investment incentives are so
algorithms are associated with
investment incentives and then we'll
take a look at well um what are the
externalities that uh result and again
that doesn't depend on the payment rule
either the payment rules you'll Rec
externalities you'll recall have to do
with the change in your payments and
those constants all cancel out so that
it's the same for all payment rules that
make the algorithm truthful um so we'll
take a look at worst case analyses of
algorithm of externalities and prove our
theorem about X cone and then um I'll
introduce an FP toas um that's robust to
Investments that will take an fbas an
existing fbas will modify it to make it
satisfy the X cone property and wind up
with one that uh preserves investment
Inc so that's the outline I'll try to
get through in the remaining
time okay so um the the first point is
that summarized in in the Box up here is
that all truthful mechanisms that use
the same algorithm X have the same
investment incentives and formally is a
theorem oh by the way the numbered
theorems are all things things that are
new in this paper not necessarily all
deep but they're all new anyway um uh
let XP and xph hat be two truthful
mechanisms that use the same algorithm X
they differ only in their payment rules
uh then for any values that the others
may have bitter ends net return uh from
an investment that changes uh VN to VN
Prime is the same for both mechanisms
and the point is of course that the uh
when you go down through the proof that
the you have differences in payments the
constants cancel um it's only the the
truthful part and this is is stated and
proved actually the paper is at the
level so this isn't just packing
problems the paper's at the uh uh at the
level of the more General problems I've
described to you uh but it applies to
the packing problems as
well okay uh the numbered theorems are
the new
ones okay um it's it's it's known and
it's been known for a long time that the
vicory Clark Grove mechanisms including
the pivot mechanism uh do uh lead to
efficient Investments uh biders profit
there are no externalities in these uh
the payments take care of the
externalities in these problems so a
bidder's profit uh is when he moves from
um well this is what this is the profit
bitter earns in the uh uh in the victory
mechanism he gets the difference between
total welfare and what total welfare
would be if his value were zero um so um
when he does something that increases
his profit it also increases total
Welfare by exactly the same amount and
so uh when faced with any given cost um
if it's profitable uh to invest it it
also increases uh total welfare net of
costs
um rogerson's theorem says that in any
vicory Clark Grove mechanism bidder's
profit increase from investment at Cost
C uh change that changes its value from
V to V hat um uh is individually
profitable if and only if it increases
net welfare and again I've explained
that okay um this is a Converse to that
theorem okay a partial Converse uh it
says that if you have a mechanism that
leads to inici efficient Investments it
must be optimizing something it doesn't
quite say that says almost says that it
must be optimizing something let's see
what almost means here um suppose that
uh an algorithm has the property that an
investment that costs C and causes n's
value to change from V to uh VN to V
hadn is individually profitable uh if
and only if it increases uh uh net
welfare so uh this is individually
profitable if and only if the uh welfare
n of costs also goes
up okay uh then there exists uh some
subset of the feasible set Omega such
that uh the welfare associated with X is
uh the uh is the maximum over this uh
constraint set so U this is almost the
same as saying that uh the only
mechanisms that lead to efficient
Investments are ones that maximize over
some set which might be a subset of the
actual feasible set it's not quite that
um it's very close to that the
difference is it says that the value of
the uh of the algorithm has to be the
same as if you were doing that and we
have a little counter example that shows
that there's some edge cases where there
are other algorithms that have the same
value but aren't selecting um uh that is
they SEL they occasionally select
something outside the set but only when
it has no impact on the value so I think
the unless you really want to get into
the details the takeaway is that the
only um uh the only algorithms that uh
uh that lead to efficient investment are
ones that um have constrained
optimization okay the almost part okay
so that's how uh uh what how algorithms
determine investment incentives uh
externalities and worst case analysis
here's an extreme but simple example um
when we wrote the first version of the
paper the referees hated this example
even though it completely nailed because
it doesn't resemble any useful algorithm
but it but it highlights the main point
and you'll see as we get into the theory
that it correctly highlights the main
point so
um this algorithm is a satisficing
algorithm for packing problems and it's
very simple algorithm if the most
valuable item that's out there is at
least 99% of the total value packet and
quit um otherwise
optimize this algorithm has a 99%
allocative guarantee it certainly will
get you at least 99% of the optimal
value okay um so but now let's consider
an investment problem that's related
using this algor them so we have uh just
two items that might be packed actually
uh it's going to be three items that I I
changed it okay three items that might
be packed sorry about that um uh bidder
one has H value zero while biders two
each have uh uh their items each have
value one um and it's feasible to pack
all the items uh so it's a really easy
problem you could pack everything so one
threshold price is zero no matter what
um uh uh one reports his payment is
going to be zero because if he pay if he
uh uh with this algorithm if he reports
anything more than zero well uh there's
no item that has more than 99% of the
value they're going to optimize and
they're going to pack him so um uh so
his threshold the thresh reporting
threshold is zero so his price is zero
in a threshold auction
okay um by investing at a cost of 200 uh
suppose that by investing at a cost of
200 bitter one can raise its value to be
200 plus Epsilon for some positive
Epsilon so he goingon to earn Epsilon
for making this investment that's a
strictly profitable investment um if he
makes that investment but um the result
of the investment when the algorithms
applied say oh there's somebody who has
99% of the total value will pack him
alone and that reduces the net value
that you could have had from two down to
Epsilon and uh worst case is zero
okay this gives you a zero fraction you
can't guarantee anything higher than a
zero fraction of the optimum from an
investment so this is a pathological
example of course but it highlights it
it's an it's extreme it gets the value
all the way down to zero uh but it
highlights what goes on and I'll show
you how in a few
moments okay so is this example too
special I I claim it's not we left it in
I claim it's not too special it ex what
it's exploiting is the fact that
approximation algorithms for the napsack
problem can have good allocative
guarantees even when they're careless
about packing um uh items that have
relatively low values and uh with
investment what can happen is that the
gross value of an item can be much
higher than its net value and um so and
you don't want to be careless about
items that have low gross values because
they're they may be the main things for
determining uh Ware so that's that is
where the possibility of large errors
comes from and that's what's uh uh
Illustrated in Spades by the previous
example okay so so let's turn to an
existing FP toas this is the bkv FP toas
for naftech problems does everybody know
what an fpas is let me just say because
there's probably some people out there
who don't know um uh it stands for fully
polinomial time approximation system and
it means that um you get to specify an
Epsilon positive Epsilon which is
the I want to achieve um I want to
guarantee when I use an algorithm that
the fraction of the optimum that I get
is at least 1 minus
Epsilon so I get at least a one minus
Epsilon fraction of the maximum possible
value and and I want a runtime which is
a polinomial function of the length of
the data and one over
Epsilon okay that's what it means to be
a fully polinomial time approximation
system so it's a set of algorithms
parameterized by Epsilon such that the
run times are polinomial in length and
one over Epsilon and the guaranteed
performance is at least to
oneus okay so um this is their algorithm
and let me go over it a little
bit so um uh this is this is what what
the algorithm looks like you're you're
you're given a value profile and it's
computer science so these are integers
um and a Target approximation ratio one
minus Epsilon and uh and and what you do
to get your approximation is you constru
conru a series of easier problems
napsack problems that are indexed by an
integer L 012 dot dot dot uh and they
work as follows so what you what we're
going to do is we're going to fix a step
size which is going to be called um
gamma Sabel for the elf problem which is
Epsilon time 2 the l ided n the number
of items that's the step size and uh and
what we're going to do is we're going to
round everything um uh to we're going to
round them down and we're going to
truncate so that the highest value
highest possible Valu is 2 to the L plus
one so we have a step size we have a
maximum possible value that gives us a a
a finite a fixed finite number uh for
each L gives us a fixed finite number of
values that each item in the
approximation can take uh so there's the
truncation step here's the rounding step
where you round down uh using the uh the
step step size and then you optimize and
it turns out that there's a polinomial
Time dynamic programming algorithm that
will find the optimum for this
approximating problem um and then what
bkv do is they uh the bkv allocation is
to they take among all these
approximating problems which are all
lower bounds for the uh actual problem
they take the one that leads to the
highest value um which is the um I guess
that's shown on several screens so I
should point with this thing they choose
the allocation um uh that corresponds to
the L that leads to the highest value
among all these approximating problems
they're all lower bounds and um and they
show that the the main theorem is that
this algorithm is monotone um it
guarantees a one minus Epsilon
approximation of the maximum it's
monotone because it's optimization is
monotone and each of these things is is
an optimization problem
okay um guarantees one minus and and it
runs in time that's polinomial in the
input size and one over
Epsilon so this is uh uh the bkv FP Tas
now um but the bkv equity test is
careless about packing small items
that's what going to be what's wrong why
is it careless what's it what it's going
to do for large L is it's going to round
the um where's the rounding step here
um the it's going to round the values
down so if you have low value items uh
if their Valu is less than the step size
it's going to round those values down to
zero and then it's going to treat them
all the same it's not going to pack them
optimally at all okay so this has in it
in a much subtler way exactly the same
problem that I showed you in the um uh
in in the satisficing algorithm
okay so um so here it is um and I the
reason I put this thing in blue is
because this is what we're going to fix
we can fix this uh just by changing the
uh last step of this algorithm um so to
take advantage of very highly valued
items because of the truncation that
takes place here and you truncate to
keep so that you have a fixed number of
the with every time you double the upper
bound you also double the uh the step
size so that you for all these problems
have the same number of possible values
that's why they're able to run in a
fixed uh an an amount of time that
doesn't vary with L um but in order to
include the most valuable items um you
have to set L large and then low value
items are are rounded to uh to zero so
uh and those low value items are
therefore going to remain
unpacked so uh theorem three um is that
for for all Delta greater than zero
there's there exists an Epsilon less
than Delta such that the B bkv rule with
parameter Epsilon has an investment
guarantee of
zero okay so it says that uh no matter
how good you can you take the bkv fbas
no matter how small you take the
approximation error uh you can't get an
investment guarantee better than zero
and that's because you can do exactly
what I did in that simpler case and uh a
proof sketch which I I'm I know I'm not
going to have time to do the proof so
it's sort of great out here but it's
really the uh uh the same trick um where
you you take uh some low value item you
create an investment opportunity where
the guy can invest a large sum of money
at a large cost to make Epsilon profit
uh it really adds nothing to the problem
it adds no no Great Value to the problem
um but it uh uh but it res results in
that the approximation that you're using
is one with a a high L because you need
to include that uh item and um and it
has exactly the same effect as the
uh 10 minutes here I'm doing okay on
time it's okay um so now how how do we
fix this how do we find um and these are
by the way these are extreme examples
I'm getting down to zero there could be
lots of things that make investment that
where investment is damaging so how do
we eliminate Investments being damaging
um so first of all how how do
Investments hurt performance so here's
the U by the way these these intuitions
all correspond to steps in the general
proof but they'll give you an idea of
how the whole thing works um consider
any packing algorithm and its threshold
auction and some investor I want you to
think about three barely profitable
investment it turns out the worst case
is all about barely profitable
Investments so I'm just going to talk
about barely profitable Investments so u
i want you to consider three barely
profitable Investments that you might be
able to make in a napsack
problem so uh the first one is investing
at Cost C raises ends value From Below
its threshold to barely above its
threshold okay so now um uh to be
profitable he's going to pay a cost of C
his value is barely above the threshold
okay so it's suppose it's Epsilon above
the threshold he's going to make a
profit of Epsilon X poost after the
investment so the cost better not be
more than Epsilon uh essentially to be
profitable the cost has to be
approximately zero uh and if the cost is
approximately zero the performance ratio
that we get from that problem with
investment is exactly the same as the
performance ratio um that we would have
had if we just just endowed the guy with
that value it it can't be that he's
doing any
damage
okay investment performance is never
worse than the allocation performance
this creates another another essentially
another allocation model so it can't
have a worst case that's worse than the
allocation worst case okay now suppose
we make an investment we have a guy
who's already above the threshold and he
makes an investment that's just barely
profitable so it means it's going to
raise his invest his value by 50 and
it's going to cost him 49.8 you know
it's makes an investment uh that's uh
he's going to pay the same price but
it's barely I'm going to call this a
confirming investment and uh by
confirming I mean you know it doesn't
have any effect on his allocation just
confirms the fact that he's packed um by
monotonicity is going to remain packed
but um uh if x reduces total welfare um
of the other packed
bids so remember we we have a packing
algorithm it could be that when I
increase my value it causes Bernard to
be unpacked if uh if that happens well
then uh then there's a a negative
externality and uh the performance is
strictly worse than without investment
um and the third one is just suppose we
invest at a cost of C to go from
Strictly below to uh to strictly above
well we can we're we're going to
decompose this case into these two cases
we're going to say the whatever the
externality uh is it all it all arises
from the part that happens after you
increase your value uh here
okay so uh the and worst cases all
involve barely profitable investment so
that's why we can uh this is of interest
to us so what the theorem four says is
that if we exclude those confirming
negative externalities those things
where uh there's the possibility that I
invest to increase my value when I'm
already packed and have an externality
and others if if that never happens then
the worst case investment performance is
just the same as the worst case
investment performance without um uh uh
in the allocative problem
okay there's there's no additional
losses resulting from the
investment okay and then there's about
uncertainty this is just the theorem
that the worst case is deterministic
yeah that's that's not a hand that's
five minutes got it okay and I'm
gonna uh and and instead I'll I'll talk
to you about an FP Tas that's robust to
Investments and here the uh the idea is
um you do EX exactly what the the BK bkv
FP toss the only thing you Chang is the
last step at the last step what they did
was um they um chose the the allocation
they chose the approx they took a look
at the value of the problem uh of the
approximating problem and noticed that
and took the highest value and uh what
we do is we take the allocation that
results from the best problem uh from
each problem and uh value it using the
actual values so they they were using
these approximate values we go through
and say okay you you decided that you're
going to pack uh him him and her uh okay
now we go back to the actual values and
say if we packed him him and her here's
what the actual Val and so we're not
using the fact that we rounded her value
down to zero when we select among these
allocations and that turns out to fix
the whole problem um the bkv uh uh it's
monotone and uh this is the old theorem
let's
see and when one invests it increases
its value sufficiently the bkv algorithm
will call cause lstar to increase um
when it increases by enough in an
example that I won't have time to show
you it causes lots of values to be
rounded down to zero uh so that's a
confirming negative externality uh which
reduces the net value to near zero um
so I'm going to use this last Last
Theorem I'll state for you and uh and
then conclude an algorithm is said to be
non bossy this is a standard notion and
mechanism designed if for all value
profiles V and V Prime in every bit or n
if you make a change that doesn't affect
your own allocation then it doesn't
affect anybody's
allocation okay that's what non bossy
means and uh theorem for packing
problems every non bossy Al algorithm is
X cone and an algorithm that outputs the
highest valued allocation from among
among other XOne algorithms is XC cone
and so if we choose among those
allocations the one with the highest
value those were all optimizing so they
were all non bossy and um uh if we
choose the one among them that leads to
the highest actual value instead of the
highest estimated value uh that is by
the second condition is also XC cone and
and um
anyway I'm running out of time but the
modified
algorithm is X cone and it's an
fpas and um that's it so there's the
summary our numbered theorems
Investments uh are the same for all
truthful mechanisms that use the same
algorithm approximation algorithms that
incentivize welfare increasing in
Investments are constrained optimizers
that has uh the bkv fpas there's zero
approximations for the investment
problem uh XOne algorithms have the same
worst case performance for both
investment and allocation problems
investment uncertainty doesn't change
worst case performance uh every non
bossy algorithm is X cone and the max of
XC con algorithms is X con and uh there
is an XC con fbas for the napsack
problem and for several of their
problems as well and that basically
is
this is do I have any time I don't have
any time right am I out of
time one minute okay the the this is uh
why we need to go farther because uh
this is a sort of a counter example
that's not covered by the uh this is if
you have randomized algorithms um the
assumption that I have made that there's
a threshold value uh is in general not
true and there's anyway I won't have
time to go over it really but there's a
um uh so the theory doesn't cover
randomized algorithms as it currently
exists and that's a pretty significant
defect that we're working on
now the unpacking problems the product
of intervals
[Applause]
that's
so
bre